the Pentagon is now backing president
Trump's plan to create a new military
branch dedicated to fighting in space
Vice President Mike Pence and defense
secretary Jim mattis laid out a
blueprint yesterday for the United
States space force David Martin is at
the Pentagon with the latest David good
morning good morning only Congress can
create a new military service and as yet
there is no estimate for how much the
space force would cost but according to
vice president pence it could happen by
2020
today other nations are seeking to
disrupt our space-based systems and
challenge American supremacy in space as
never before like the Army Navy Air
Force Marines and Coast Guard the new
space force would prepare for war a war
in space against countries like Russia
and China the US military depends on
some 140 satellites including this
quarter billion dollar GPS satellite for
everything from communications to
targeting the enemy but Air Force
secretary Heather Wilson says many of
those satellites were built at a time
when there was no threat of attack
we built the glass houses before the
invention of stones
the threat to us satellites has been
increasing since 2007 when China used a
ground-based anti-satellite weapon to
shoot down one of its old weather
satellites 530 miles above the earth
General J Raymond showed 60 minutes the
results this is about 3,000 pieces
debris just from that one event that
came just from that one collision just
from that one collision defense
secretary James Madison aliy opposed to
the space force idea writing in a 2000
17 letter it would add layers of
bureaucracy but his position seems to be
changing
we are
complete alignment with the president's
concern about protecting our assets in
space as the commander-in-chief
continues to push the idea space force
people
there are currently about 18,000 men and
women in uniform involved in space
operations although president Trump's
says the space force would be separate
and equal to the other branches it would
be by far the smallest of the military
services glad alright David Martin thank
you very much